[Musica]
[Applauso]
eccomi qua io nella vita
svolgono una professione se tale come
tale possiamo definirla un po
particolare e dal dal nome decisamente
accattivante del resto me lo sono
inventato faccio l'adventure rider molti
di voi si staranno chiedendo in questo
momento stanno domandando ma questo voi
cosa fa nella vita
bene per farla breve io costruisco
progetti di viaggio un po particolari
dove vado unire la mia passione per il
viaggio per l'avventura per la natura ha
tutto quello che un po mi può portare a
vivere la situazione stessi nella
maniera un po più complicata un po più
difficile un po più estrema
io sono un motociclista ma sono anche un
avventuriero che ha deciso di
abbandonare gli age della vita
quotidiana di città per intraprendere
una strada un pelino un po più
complicata una sfida che mi porta
affrontare ogni giorno a spingermi a
superare i miei limiti
del resto basta a creare il nuovo
progetto e scegliere la nuova meta
decidere il mezzo da utilizzare che non
necessariamente deve essere una moto può
essere un qualsiasi veicolo una volta
scelta l'attrezzatura l'abbigliamento e
l'equipaggiamento il gioco è fatto
via e si parte in questa questa era dove
i social fanno letteralmente da padrone
mi sono reso conto che tutto questo era
possibile infatti io collaboro anche con
aziende del settore adventure fornendo
loro contenuti audio video foto che
possono essere utilizzati soprattutto
principalmente sui canali web da queste
collaborazioni da queste
sponsorizzazioni oltre a ottenere una
collaborazione tecnica con la fornitura
degli equipaggiamenti
e dei mezzi o anche una retribuzione che
mi permette di mantenere sia me stesso
che i miei viaggi sport avventura e la
natura nelle sue mille innumerevoli
sfaccettature sono sempre stati gli
elementi fondamentali della mia vita
della mia esistenza fonte d'ispirazione
per nuove avventure fonti di ispirazioni
per nuove viaggi carica di adrenalina
perché alla fine l'adrenalina e la parte
principale delle mie sfide delle mie
avventure in poche parole avete capito
che io mi occupo di di sfide ed è
proprio ultimamente che la vita mi ha
offerto una nuova sfida
forse la più difficile la più complicata
forse quella in supero insuperabile
la montagna più dura da scalare o il
sentiero più impervio di off road da
percorrere con la mia moto
tutto è iniziato dieci mesi fa quando
appunto attraverso i social instagram
in questo caso sono stato contattato da
una donna da una mamma devastata e ormai
priva di forze di ogni speranza
il cui figlio dall'età di 12 anni e
mezzo è stato letteralmente inghiottito
da questo mondo surreale e violento
chiamato droga una donna totalmente una
donna dove giovane una madre giovane
totalmente devastata che però provo un
amore proprio imprescindibile è
fortissimo nei confronti del proprio
vino del proprio figlio nathan che ogni
giorno però lo vede allontanarsi sempre
di più allontanarsi da lei e ad
allontanarsi da tutto il mondo che lo
circonda risucchiato da questo buco nero
che lo sta inghiottendo lentamente
questa donna le ha tentate proprio tutte
percorso qualsiasi e via percorribile
servizi sociali cliniche psichiatriche
comunità educatori di tutto di più ogni
tentativo è stato un fallimento ogni
tentativo andato vano
perché ormai il ragazzo si è creato una
sua nuova identità la sua nuova figura
la sua nuova persona è diventato molto
più forte di tutte queste cose ha
iniziato all'età di 12 anni e mezzo a
consumarsi i primi spinelli primi
cannoni di marijuana e di hashish per
poi avere un escalation crescente
passando dalla ketamina alla
metanfetamina agli acidi alle pasticche
fino arrivare alla cocaina e l'eroina
sniffata praticamente qualsiasi cosa gli
capitasse a tiro
e questa dipendenza fisica e psichica è
stata velocissima devastante tenendo
conto anche dell'età dell'adolescente
oltre a questa dipendenza si è andata
aggiungere un ulteriore dipendenza
quella degli psicofarmaci
questi farmaci che gli venivano dati nei
centri di recupero che stavano tentando
di salvarlo lui ormai era dipendente da
tutto oltre a questa dipendenza si è
associata anche quella dell'alcol
praticamente un disastro io ho iniziato
a vedermi con questa donna a
frequentarla ea cercare di capire a
cercare di comunicare con lei capire
cosa stesse realmente succedendo volevo
sapere tutto il trascorso di lei della
famiglia del passato delle cliniche dei
fallimenti
volevo cercare di capire il perché di
tutto questo
del resto il mio pensiero mio primo
pensiero è che se si è rivolta a me alla
fine lei si è rivolta a un pazzo perché
sono fondamentalmente un pazzo e
arrivare a questo punto vuol dire che ti
stai giocando l'ultimo gettone proprio
l'ultima chance che hai per salvare il
ragazzo proprio da un destino ormai
certo nelle settimane successive iniziò
a frequentare anche il ragazzo del resto
io devo conquistare la sua fiducia devo
conquisti di stabilire un rapporto con
lui il rapporto che nessuno prima d'ora
era mai riuscito a stabilire il mio
punto di forza sono i miei racconti
cerco di conquistarlo con i paesaggi con
l'avventura con vari episodi che mi sono
successi in giro per il mondo ma di
fronte ho sempre un muro proprio un muro
costante
non ho nessuna risposta non ho proprio
un argomento che ci possa unire se non
il suo argomento principale perché se si
parla di droghe e di tutto quello che è
legato al mondo della droga
lui il numero uno io continuo a
domandarmi il perché sono veramente
incazzato vado a casa la sera tutte le
secondo lo vedo arrivo a casa incazzato
perché non riesco a capacitarmi di come
un ragazzino di 15 anni possa buttare
così al vento la sua vita perché si vive
in effetti si vive una volta sola
però io non ho neanche una preparazione
in materia non sono né psicologo e
psichiatra non ho nessuno nessun titolo
a riguardo anzi a volte ne avrai bisogno
io sono solo una sorta di pazzo nomade
nel mondo libero e felice
ed è proprio la pazzia la follia un
momento di follia che mi spingono a
pensare una cosa se io devo conquistare
questo ragazzo devo essere semplicemente
me stesso devo fare l'unica cosa che so
fare
i viaggi l'avventura inizia a pensare a
un progetto dove decide di portarlo in
un viaggio che va da cile argentina e
bolivia
inizio a parlarne con la madre di questo
progetto perché alla fine questo sarà un
viaggio che io ho definito un viaggio
impossibile
avevo poche speranze però voluto farlo
perché alla fine le sfide fanno parte di
me
una volta avuta l'autorizzazione da
parte della mamma arrivato il momento di
comunicarlo al ragazzo parlo con nathan
gli faccio la proposta e lui così come
per magia mi risponde va bene d'accordo
però mi dice così addio a un'unica
condizione l'importante che ci sia
l'erba vabbe io non posso negare di don
dargli l'erba durante il viaggio mento
perché alla fine
l'importante è non rovinare questo
viaggio ancora sul nascere quando mi
rendo conto di quello che sto per
realizzare del viaggio che sto
intraprendere per la prima volta sorge
in me anche un certo senso di paura di
timore perché la fine
la cosa che mi spaventa di più in lui
sono le crisi di astinenza crisi di
astinenza perché questo ragazzo fino al
giorno fino al giorno della decisione
della partenza per il viaggio
lui non ha mai fatto più di tre giorni
senza consumare stupefacenti
ce ne aspettano 45 va bene
l'unica cosa che io tengo dirà lui prima
di partire è una cosa molto importante
che mi rispecchia molto che ogni viaggio
ti lascia qualcosa ritorni che sei
cambiato e io spero vivamente che da
questo viaggio
nathan possa ritornare cambiato
decidiamo di partire partiamo alla volta
di santiago del cile
cerco di impostare i primi giorni di
viaggio su due principi fondamentali che
un po mi si addicono l'amicizia e il
rispetto l'amicizia decido di
alloggiarvi con germi con nathan a casa
di un mio caro amico cileno juan
francisco che ci ospita perché l'ho
portato fino lì per fargli capire il
vero significato dell'amicizia per far
capire a questo ragazzo che gli amici si
possono avere amici amici belli e veri
in ogni angolo del pianeta e noi gli
amici non è che devono essere per forza
i suoi amici legato a quel mondo marcio
della droga ed al secondo argomento e
rispetto lo porta in casa di un estraneo
perché lui deve imparare anche a
rispettare delle regole cose che fino ad
adesso non aveva più fatto
dopo alcuni giorni a casa del mio amico
cileno ci mettiamo in viaggio
ovviamente in moto decidono di fare una
prima tappa di abbastanza corta 300 400
km
arriviamo a destinazione montiamo la
tenda mangiamo passiamo alcuni momenti
insieme dopo di che iniziano apparire le
prime avvisaglie le avvisaglie di una
cosa che fondamentalmente in quel
momento non mi stavo aspettando della
prima crisi di astinenza
il ragazzo a freddo in quel momento
fuori ci sono 42 gradi a dolore ovunque
mi dice che gli fanno male gli organi mi
dice che gli tira il cuore è diventato
irascibile nervoso e anche aggressivo
nei miei confronti perché sta usando
anche la minaccia per ottenere quello
che deve avere lui oltretutto è a
conoscenza che con me o degli
psicofarmaci da usare in caso di
evenienza e lui è un gran manipolatore
perché dove c'era la droga c'è menzogna
e c'è manipolazione il viaggio nei
giorni successivi continua tra crisi di
astinenza
tra crisi psichiche addirittura attacchi
epilettici notturni alti e bassi un
susseguirsi di alti e bassi proprio una
maniera incostante fino ad arrivare a un
giorno che molto probabilmente è stato
uno dei giorni più pesanti nella mia
vita una cicatrice indelebile dietro di
dentro di me
il ragazzo vogliamo dirlo così ha
tentato di infliggersi del male
lanciandosi dalla moto in corsa è caduto
e rotolato la visione rovinosamente si è
rialzato non si è fatto nulla ed è
scappato io in quel momento ho avuto un
momento di totale riflessione ho pensato
a tutto quello che aveva provato la
mamma negli anni precedenti al viaggio
decido così di resettare un po il tutto
ci fermiamo due giorni tre giorni a casa
di un altro mio amico argentino e li
cerco di ristabilire quel filo sottile
che ci stava legando perché il nostro
rapporto era proprio legato da un filo
sottile del resto siamo gli opposti
iniziamo così a viaggiare e dopo questi
due giorni io mi accorgo che il nathan è
cambiato qualcosa inizia avere un po di
più di propensione verso la vita un po
più gli stimoli inizia a essere anche
interessato al viaggio e si rende anche
conto che stiamo viaggiando in moto cosa
che fino a quel giorno non era entrato
proprio nella sua testa inizia a essere
collaborativo mi aiuta a montare la
tenda mi aiuta cucinare
gli viene anche voglia di mangiare
perché purtroppo lui mangiava almeno una
volta a settimana sotto minaccia
inizia a mangiare inizia a dormire
passano le crisi epilettiche c'è sempre
qualche crisi qualche alto e basso
qualche crisi di pianto qualche crisi di
di nervoso però il discorso della droga
non viene più tirato in considerazione
non parla più della droga e io nei suoi
occhi inizio a vedere anche degli occhi
diversi se prima vedevo degli occhi buy
privi di amore privi di qualsiasi cosa
privi di ambizioni e privi di sony
adesso nei suoi occhi
inizio a vedere anche la felicità e
soprattutto a regalarmi qualche sorriso
perché io non ho mai visto sorridere
quel ragazzo fino a quel giorno passano
così velocemente i nostri 45 giorni on
the road ed è il momento di arrivare di
tornare indietro
una cosa che mi ha colpito molto e che
quando la sera prima di rientrare io ero
molto dispiaciuto perché sono
fondamentalmente dispiaciuto ogni volta
che devo tornare a casa da un viaggio ma
la cosa che mi ha colpito è che lui per
l'ennesima volta mi guarda e mi dice fra
ma dobbiamo già tornare quindi dentro di
me avevo capito che avevo fatto qualcosa
che ero riuscito
oppure ero riuscito a iniziare un nuovo
cammino per questo ragazzo
torniamo a casa e la prima cosa che mi
stupisce di lui il primo traguardo
conquistato da nathan nathan non va alla
ricerca delle droghe io invece mi
rinchiuso in casa e inizio pensare
inizio a pensare che fondamentalmente
sono riuscito a fare qualcosa di
incredibile
qualcosa di forte e qualcosa di
veramente bello per questo ragazzo non
me lo sarei mai immaginato soprattutto
tornando a pensare alla mia frase ogni
viaggio ti lascia qualcosa quando tornai
sei cambiato questa volta nathan era
davvero cambiato o perlomeno aveva
iniziato a cambiare il ragazzo
praticamente
dovrà iniziare un suo percorso che non
sarà più con me al fianco dovrà riuscire
a vincere a vincere delle battaglie a
vincere a raccogliere delle piccole
soddisfazioni in modo da riuscire in
qualcosa e la fine del viaggio la fine
di ogni viaggio alla fine del mio
viaggio del nostro viaggio coincide
sempre con una nuova partenza
in questo caso a me molto probabilmente
toccherà una nuova sfida toccherà una
nuova avventura così sarà anche per
nathan perché lui torna rinforzato da
questa esperienza da questo viaggio e
dovrà affrontare il suo nuovo viaggio il
suo nuovo viaggio sarà quello di
intraprendere un nuovo percorso dovrà
scrivere la sua storia dovrà raggiungere
degli obiettivi da questa esperienza
potrà servire ad altri ragazzi come
esempio per conquistare e per riuscire a
conquistare e vincere sul mondo della
droga
io di certo non sarò presente
costantemente nella vita di nathan
esattamente rimarrò un amico lo aiuterò
sempre ci sarò sempre però di certo sua
madre
i nuovi amici il centro di recupero e
sostegno che lo accoglierà lo aiuteranno
gli daranno una mano suggerendogli la
strada però sarà nathan a dover
affrontare il viaggio il proprio viaggio
per giungere alla meta e per giungere la
sua transitional lasciando alle spalle
le stanze buie del passato piene di
tristezza di arrendevolezza e alla fine
fare una cosa bellissima affrontare il
suo nuovo mondo grazie
[Applauso]